as more young people like David pull up
in their rooms with their devices
studies show a generation Delaine
adulthood fewer get driver's licenses
have after-school jobs or date but most
alarming the suicide rate for girls ages
15 to 19 doubled between 2007 and 2015
dr. Larry Rosen a leading psychologist
is especially concerned about what all
this tech is doing to developing brains
we know what the blue light does to
their brain
night after night of leaves these little
molecules called beta-amyloid and they
build into plaques and when they look at
the brains of Alzheimer's patients they
have a lot of plaque in their brains and
I think that we're heading toward a
major problem as these kids have been
using phones for the last ten years
start to get into their 20s 30s and 40s
I think we're going to start seeing a
lot of memory problems coming up Wow
that's pretty scary Tech is not only
affecting our brains it's also affecting
our creativity when you are being
creative or your mind is wandering or
you're dreaming or daydreaming a
different part of your brain is
activated a part of what we're doing to
ourselves as well as our kids is that
we're not allowing enough at that time
because it's so easy to just pull out
your phone and check the news or
whatever it doesn't matter it stifles
your ability to live within boredom and
boredom is important because boredom
then clicks in the creative activities
we don't allow ourselves to get bored
anymore want more exclusive content from
America inside app we'll just click one
of these videos floating next to me